Millions of years after the Big Bang, some
stars formed.
These could've been the first stars that brought
light into the universe.
These stars formed right after the “DARK
AGES”- which by the way is the time AFTER
the Big Bang but BEFORE there was any light,
where the universe was filled with just dark
gas.
Astronomers found these very first stars by
using a radio telescope out in Western Australia.
Radio telescopes are cool because they are
able to detect radio waves, which are the
longest wavelength known to exist in our universe,
meaning it can detect stuff that’s traveled
great distances to get to us.
Based on changes detected in the Cosmic Microwave
Background Radiation, astronomers were able
to create models SUGGESTING that 180 million
years after the Big Bang, these first stars
formed.
This adds to previous research, and now we
are lead to believe that these first stars
were probably BLUE stars, and based on the
spectral classifications of stars we know
that blue stars hot, young, short-lived stars, that die naturally by a
supernova explosion or a collapse of its core
into a black hole.
By using instruments at the Murchison Radio
Astronomy Observatory, astronomers picked
up dips in the frequency received from the
early universe, and THIS represents the moment
that stars first formed and began interacting
with the matter around them.
Not only can this lead us into a better understanding
of our early universe, and its evolutionary
stages…
But according to the scientists, this could
possibly be the work of cold dark matter particles
pulling energy away from the hydrogen gas
and cooling it down.
This is all speculation of course, since we
still don't have confirmation of dark matter
existing, BUT this new info could help!
So let’s see what more research there is
to come out of this finding... because early
universe understandings means getting closer
to finding the meaning of life.
Greetings peeps!
Like learning about star stuff?
Check out this video Trace did on starquakes!
One last thing...
The data collected from this research came
from giant radio telescope antennas that are
not much different than those on your FM radio.